I wish is this another found footage
movie already kill him for you yeah what
Jeff oh no it's a home video of murder
my name is Lester Burnham dead guy
narration that's our next-door neighbor
Jim and that's his lover Jim look I'm
all for same-sex couples but I am NOT
okay with same name couplings okay lots
of things going on here we know Jane is
saving up for a boob job but my question
is does she take care of the family's
bills and if so what is the rent portion
or are the Burnham's making their
sixteen-year-old daughter pay five
hundred sixty-five dollars to stay here
also she makes a deposit of 3806 into
the account which with all the other
bills means the family's going to go
broke in about three months you will
later see Jane's boobs in this movie and
I would like to figure out where she got
the idea that she needs a boob job could
you make me a little later please
because I'm not quite late enough
seriously this married couple with one
child has two incomes and they don't
have a spare car Helen they can't afford
a junker of some sort sanam is marijuana
I use the company MasterCard I pay for
that hooker um win in 1999 or for that
matter ever do prostitutes take credit
cards and if you were a prominent
businessman would you give a hooker a
credit card for any reason and how does
Lester know this movie feels like office
space with a whole efficiency expert
thing and the right something justifying
your position in the company and
downsizing stuff but then also feels
like Fight Club with the whole black
male the guy firing you into a year
salary thing I'm not saying it means
anything but it sure is weird right
especially since all three films came
out in 1999 am I losing my mind
stalking also as you'll see despite the
fact that the Burnham's are a family on
the brink they still leave their windows
unblocked for all sorts of activities
and some of them end up being crucial to
the plot hey she doesn't like her
parents either I'm glad they put his
comments in quotes otherwise I would
never have believed he actually said
this why did she save all this fuckin
cleaning for the day of the actual open
house
well that's salut aka John Chow aka
Herald in 1999 holy SH I didn't realize
he was in this movie damn dawg
this is still the best movie you've ever
been in I didn't sell this house today
face movie tries to make me believe this
goth rebellious cargo pants wearing hate
daughter is a cheerleader on
she's gonna resent it I'm missing the
James Bond Marathon on TNT yeah but
they're doing the Timothy don't ones
right now Leicester fantasizes about
high school girls and I'm okay with that
no I am NOT okay with that in my fantasy
the rose petals stayed inside the
sweater and I think he and your mother
have not had sex in a long time
yeah sure but he jerked it in the shower
this morning so he should definitely be
able to keep his composure around high
school girls better than he did
convenient petal placement these two
high school girls in 1999 are smoking
weed while listening to a 1972 song by
Bill Withers
in other words this would never happen
yeah I think the creepy asshole neighbor
who shoots videos in the dark might like
me this book lists Jane's dad's work
number is five five five one two five
one but earlier he told the guy over the
phone to call him at five five five oh
one nine nine also mom's work number and
cell phone is a 3:1 to Chicago number
while the number she puts on all the
real estate signs and listings is in 847
Chicago number calling your daughter's
underage best friend is one thing not
having a plan when she answers is
another the shower shuts off and within
three seconds Jane comes out of the
bathroom wrapped in a towel that is
amazing speed Angela's room is an orgy
of evidence that she's really into
modeling this kid's going to be shown
down a super strict home life but is not
only a high-end weed dealer but also has
huge stretches of unsupervised time
where he's constantly filming neighbors
voyeuristically ricky openly doing drug
dealer math in front of his father I
know his father is so cliche he doesn't
see anything we don't want him to see
but damn
let us some stupid shit how come these
faggots always have to rub it in your
face that's racist so stop acting like
you're goddamned Christy Turlington god
damn Christy Turlington all the way down
to the bone of the wood I mean is this
supposed to be a clue for the audience
that Frank is secretly gay it has to be
right but it's such a hit you over the
head kind of thing it's way more
offensive than it probably intended to
be sarcastic PDA Daniel of on Robin Hood
trail Ricky just happens to be working
at a real estate party where Lester is
so that the Cheech and Chong portion of
the film can happen to party do you get
high actually the first question implies
coke more than it does wheat Laster
she's actually looking for him out here
that's something you expect me to
believe this woman would do cuz um
bullshit
also this appears to be an emergency
exit despite not having sounded an alarm
all the times we've seen it opened in
this movie
someone is behind the fridge door when
they close it cliche
repeating things I'm going to commit
statutory rape face Angela and Janie
just happened to be talking about the
very thing that Lester is interested in
and when you're good-looking you can get
away with anything come to America's
weirdest home video dude that's all your
choice right you could like not shoot a
naked man lifting weights next door but
you decide to do it anyway also working
out sorry so what - backs doors are
always locking themselves on accident
are can I give it to you in the morning
I just took a whiz this kid is 18 why is
he still living at home and taking piss
tests he makes thousands of dollars
selling drugs so what the fuck your
fantasies are horrible very very dirty
whoa whoa that won't get her clean at
all I don't know what's more sinful him
whacking off in bed with his wife or his
wife being shocked that her husband of
this many years wax on you like just one
of the most popular bands ever yeah
weird how much to grant apparently
Lister can afford $2,000 worth a week
but can't get a frickin car to drive to
work well there's a car there with my
beeper number which is insanely stupid
for a drug dealer to include in all of
his bags a week wait they do have a
second car then what the hell is going
on with that insane carpool every
morning my job consists of basically
masking my contempt for the assholes in
charge
this letter is freaking awesome I'm
removing a sin because it's basically
what most of us want to tell our bosses
can you prove that you didn't offer to
save my job if I let you blow me um the
burden of proof would be on you luster
but somehow this works and he gets a
whole year's salary for nothing what an
asshole this guy is no what I do what I
feel like what I fire of course you do
because everyone in this movie is going
to be a suspect when Lester gets shot
hmm tough to see but how about walking
on the sidewalk the thing made for
walking around my dad hides out I see
this movie should have been going guns
and roses you want to see the most
beautiful thing I've ever film now
that's what I call over selling also
floating bag beats your dumb ass Janie
also the floating bag is the most
beautiful thing he's ever filmed it has
a poor excuse I know but it helps me
remember because marijuana is known to
affect short-term memory
this girl is somehow moved by the
floating bag footage oh oh and I want to
thank you for putting me
the added pressure of being the sole
breadwinner now okay being mad at him
for blackmailing his boss and everything
but did you not hear that he got a
$60,000 severance package
I understand they want to make Carol in
this horrible shrew of a person but this
kind of ignorance is going too damn far
okay well I just got bitch-slapped by my
mom time to show my tits to my neighbor
Ricky likes to film floating bags but
not the fun kind how did you get in
there take the lock sure my question is
how did you become such an amazing
detective did you tie a strand of hair
in front of your Nazi plate cabinet
doors and find it broken or missing oh
is the camera the question I've been
asking the whole movie happens to be a
lot about me that you don't know mr.
spiney man and that bending is a great
actress and she got nominated for an
Oscar for this but this character my god
you never once see her in a good light
she never has a winning moment I mean if
we can give Ricky as dead birds then
surely we could give her like a moment
where she does or says something
redeeming Lester you're gonna spill beer
on the couch just when she looks like
she's gonna be cool for once
the filmmaker say nope this character
this is just stuff and it's become more
important to you than living well honey
that's just nuts said the guy who just
bought a classic sports car don't dude
turn the camera off and you might get
some real action naked I'm naked
I enjoyed this post-coital film each
other and talk about deep scene I really
do I'm just curious how this is going on
in his room in the house of the
overbearing father who's strict
discipline he's currently talking about
where he's not even supposed to lock his
door Annie smoking weed in here too
maybe I can buy the dad being dumb
enough to fall for the fake piss test
crap maybe but that dad would sure smell
that weed even if he's out of the house
right now he'd smell it upon returning
I've been babysitting since I was about
10 I've got almost $3,000 and paying all
sorts of bills that you cannot sustain
on a $38 per babysit salary Lester has
Ricky's patron number for future weed
purchases but he chooses to do this call
me thing in front of Frank so that Frank
can get wrong ideas about his son and
the inevitable conclusion of this plot
can happen paranoia and suspicious
father completely misses the obvious
secret compartment hole okay this is a
pretty important plan turn here when the
father finds the tape he thinks means
his son is gay but why of all the tapes
he shot recently with this one be
sitting right next to the camera and not
the post sex tape he made with his
girlfriend or the floating bag tape he
showed his girlfriend and why is the
naked Lester workout tape at a spot in
the middle
I mean he was shooting Lester before
Lester disrobe and even settle on a
dialogue on how weird this site is which
might have helped his dad not think he
was gay and the tapes started at the
beginning instead of the naked part I
guess what I'm saying is convenient gay
misunderstanding tape ex machina of
course because Carolyn was totally
completely oblivious to Lester when he
said he had a new job they'd go to the
place where he asked the new job even in
1999 you could not order two combos with
fries and shakes and pay only 798 how
much time is supposed to have passed in
this movie I thought it was a few weeks
or so but if you've ever tried working
out your arms and pecs you know these
kind of results are simply not possible
in that shorter period of time
drug-dealing child of imposing evil
parents leaves his drug dealer beeper on
during family dinners after one next
door Jan Lester John should book in my
bag and she can't possibly call a phone
number to do that unbelievable I is
unbelievable and if I were this kid I
wouldn't do drug deals in lit rooms of
the home next door to my prime father
I'm just saying here we have that con in
Hollywood trope convenient home
construction leads to blowjob
misunderstanding also coincidence is
given a nice assist from Kevin Spacey
doing the traditional blowjob receiving
arm formation despite the fact he's
watching a joint control ah yeah this is
the most relaxing joint rolling I've
ever seen it's so peaceful we really
honor our character keep saying gay
sounding things despite the character
not being remotely gay it is this is one
of those great myths they trying to
teach us around this time and people
still believe it today people who are
huge homophobes must be secretly gay so
what I'm wondering is why is all this
taking place in the living room right
now Carolyn can come home in any moment
his daughter and boyfriend are just up
the stairs if not for the fact that she
says she's a virgin and he stops they're
going to fuck right here for anyone to
see it how did this go from let's run
away to New York right now - let's look
up at the ceiling in bed while your dad
tries to bang your best friend she's
really happy she she's in love I feel no
need to tell you that upstairs right now
she's planning on running away with
Ricky to New York that totally slipped
my mind during this almost statutory
bonding moment secret killer who is not
the wife conveniently uses the same gun
we saw in the wife's possession earlier
so the audience can remain in the dark
damn if only I had my camera also why
isn't Janey screaming her lungs out
right now we know she was having some
issues with her dad but damn we knew she
also still loved him - she just watching
this like it's no big deal
Dan it took her forever to walk to the
door
got out of the car right after Lester
and Angela were done with there were not
banging because she's a virgin hug also
how did Carolyn not see Frank running
anywhere during the time she was outside
does he do everything through the back
door Oh
even when Carolyn looks genuinely upset
about her husband getting shot and she
has no idea who did it the only thing
she can think about is hiding her own
gun also Carolyn doesn't even seem to be
worried that there's a killer on the
loose who might still be in the house
hell nobody does Ricky's trying to
decide if Lester's death is more
beautiful than his floating bag
meanwhile the killer just shot Lester
for unknown reasons and could be
anywhere but it's hard to stay mad when
there's so much beauty in the world to
quote a certain drug dealer I enjoyed
buying weed from you don't get to tell
me what to do ever again
this is my neighborhood it's a beautiful
day in this neighborhood the beautiful
Volker neighbor what would you say you
do here look I already told you I deal
with the goddamn customers so the
engineers don't have to are you
threatening me
no get the fuck out of here your fire
have a better solution you keep me on
the payroll as an outside consultant
that's what I love about these high
school girls man
I get older they stay the same a
and fright
hey boy act happy tonight you're happy I
hate that that's right I was choking the
bishop chafing the carrot you know
saying hi to my monster taking the old
log to the beaver taking the skin ball
to tune it down taking a ride and the
wild baloney Pony Chris I was saving it
up for a boob job but extreme closeup
Wow okay extreme move it's just hot
couch but that's the point we see a
deadly sin on every street corner in
every home and we tolerate it we
tolerate it because it's common if you
take your clothes off and now I don't
know if that's even legal the rest of
the time you're just another
good-looking sweet-talking charm oozing
happy fella with nothing to offer but
some dialog why don't you run outside
and jerk yourself a soda